area let's take just a minute to review
where we are in terms of our reading of
this complicated
which letter we started out by saying
that one of the purposes of the letter
is to introduce Paul to a congregation
he doesn't know partly to bless him as
he passes through Rome on his way to
Spain where I think he feels he'll
conclude his mission
partly to get their blessing for the
offering he's taking to Jerusalem and
probably partly to help them think
through what it means to be a Jewish
Christian and the Gentile Christian will
come back to the word Christian in a
minute but Gentile believer Christian
believer in Jesus Christ that then in
chapters 1 2 3 what Paul needs to do who
does do successfully I think is set up
the claim that everybody needs Jesus and
the reason everybody needs Jesus is that
everybody has sinned and fallen short of
the glory of God in his language Jews by
breaking of the law Gentiles by their
idolatry which which breaks a law
written on their hearts the law of the
Creator God who can't be confused with
God's creations and and so what is going
to redeem people as Jesus Christ and the
way one relates to Jesus Christ is
twofold it's through Christ's own
faithfulness Christ's faithful obedience
to God but also our faithful loyalty to
Jesus Christ
who is faithful to God the word faith
gets tossed around in lots of ways and
then Abraham becomes the first great
type or illustration of that kind of
belief because he trusts in God's
promise to bring forth out of his own
barren out of Sarah's barrenness and his
own age the gift of Isaac and that
becomes a promise of what God will do in
Jesus Christ which is to bring forth
blessing out of nothingness and life out
of death and when when Abraham trusts
that then it's counted to him as
righteousness he moves into a right
relationship with God that becomes an
example for the Roman believers I think
where we are at the end of chapter 4
thanks for that update you're most
welcome
you use the term Christian yes or
inflict on that just a little bit does
Paul have the category Paul does not
have the catio Christian Paul standard
way of talking about believers are those
who are in Christ and what he wants to
insist in Romans as in his other letters
is that Gentiles can be in Christ just
as much as Jews can be in Christ and
that in Christ they find their identity
it leads to a whole bunch of puzzles
which is who did Paul think he was
religiously my assumption is he thought
he was a
Jew who was in Christ not that he was
this new thing called a Christian but
that's a huge puzzle for another day
what I will simply listen to your wisdom
on it because I sure haven't figured it
out no in Christ is the operative
category in Christ the operative carry
and he wants to insist that both Jews
and non-jews Gentiles can be part of
that reality just a quick nod to that
that that's not simply a somatic
difference to be in Christ is has to do
with one's whole identity one's whole
being one's relational we one's
relational aspect in terms of God in
terms of Christ it's one thing to say
you and I are Christian that's fair
enough it's where we go to church and
where we pay our tithes but to say that
we're in Christ as I say our lives are
defined by that relationship but I think
he wants to make that stronger claim
Christian can weaken it I think for him
right it's interesting to think about
this in language that uses and will be
bumping up against some of it a little
bit later in Romans there's also Christ
in us as we absolutely right absolutely
he is explicit about that I live now not
i but Christ in me in Christ Alicia yeah
and some people have talked about this
as kind of participatory mysticism or
criticism I don't know mysticism is the
right word but relationality is sorry
there aren't words it is more as we said
back at the beginning belief is more
than what you do intellectually it has
to do with where you put your soul and
the participation language I think helps
in that and Paul I want to I wanted to
move on from Abraham you said I think
quite rightly that we need to see at the
end of chapter 3 that Paul thinks he's
sustaining the law and he's sustaining
the law because for him law doesn't just
mean a bunch of rules law means Torah
what what does Moses say about the truth
and he thinks contemporary Hebrew
scholars to the contrary notwithstanding
that he's a pretty smart interpreter of
the Torah he said that Abraham
prefigures those who are in Christ
now in Chapter five he has another big
prefiguration and that's Adam and what
does he what'd he do with Adam in
Chapter five before I answer your on
Adam I want to just say a word about at
the beginning of chapter five and pick
up on some of this relation okay a
business that we've been talking about
because one of the things that
happens between four and five is that
Paul shifts his metaphors yeah if in
Chapter four the main metaphor is
reckoning or justification which comes
from the legalese we hear what Paul
Purdue uses here at the beginning of
chapter five is relational language
about reconciliation and he's probably
picking this up from some of his work in
second Corinthians in particular which
was all about getting reconciled to a
community that had severed its
relationships with was truly annoyed at
him you know and so just look at the way
in which he opens this therefore since
we since we are justified by faith we
have peace with God through our Lord
Jesus Christ through whom we have
obtained access this is almost the
language of patron client relations it
is how do I get into the house we
obtained access to this grace in which
we stand and we boast in a hope of
sharing the glory of God this
relationship has an eschatological
dimension that's going to loom larger
Roger vary as the argument moves on and
it also has an ethical dimension right
and he goes into that in verse three not
only that but we also boast in our
sufferings knowing that suffering
produces endurance and endurance
produces character and character
produces hope so here's the hope theme
built upon the transformation of
character that comes from this life of
faith and just quickly the Holy Spirit
who will write who will also reappear
before long so a rich collection of
tapestry of and then the reconciliation
language and what what follows okay so
that's the invocation yeah I think it's
helpful to see all this because Paul
talks in more than one way as you
pointed out before about what has
happened through Christ you know so in
verse 12 he picks up on the Adam
typology and this is something he had
used once before in first Corinthians
when he was worried about what
resurrection means and it might be
useful to think about that for just a
moment because in 1st Corinthians 15 he
had been challenged by some people and
the corinthian community who were
denying the reality of resurrection and
so paul wants to say no it
a reality even if it's going to be
different from anything that we can
imagine and he's he uses the atom Christ
typology to say God created Adam in the
first place as a living being God
created the new Adam Christ in a very
new way a spiritual being we share in
that but here he's not making an
argument about resurrection he's making
an argument about sin which has been
they the dominating theme since the
first couple of chapters and he wants to
say it wants to reaffirm that sin is a
universal reality and that God's
gracious action in dealing with it
Trump's it no matter how abrasive and
how deleterious that the fact of sin has
been the fact of God's grace is far far
surpasses it so that's the fundamental
nobody wants to make and in doing that
he goes back to the beginning to a
damage of the story in Genesis he's the
Bible is resonating here and in his
arguments throughout usually sometimes
in the form of specific quotations
sometimes in just by an allusion to the
story yeah so he alludes to the story of
the the firsts in the garden and does so
in verse 12 therefore just as sin came
into the world through one man and death
came through sin and so death spread to
all because all have sinned and that he
does yeah one of his broken up sentences
right as he often does he his thought
moves faster than his grammar some cases
are but then he I want to go back to
what he said because this is often taken
to be a proof text for a doctrine of
original sin and that doctrine was aided
actually in the Latin tradition because
of a different translation or a
different way of rendering the end of
that verse instead of because all have
sinned it's in whom all have sinned
right which is actually a mistranslation
of the Greek yeah so Paul doesn't
doesn't have that notion of original sin
in the same way in which will be
developed by Agustin right he does have
a notion that seen as a universal
reality and there's a scriptural warrant
for that in the story of Adam and he's
already showed us in
for chapters 1 & 2 how that that's right
plays out in the Roman community that's
right and I think it's clear how he
thinks about this in the next verse that
people sin like at Adam yeah yeah yeah
so much because yeah so Adam like
Abraham is a type he represents some
aspect of human reality and on the other
side we have the free gift the free gift
of God's reconciling love in Christ that
trumps sin now the other thing that's
going on here is Paulus is wrestling
with this this reality of sin and the
reality of God's grace is the law yeah
and one thing about these these several
chapters from the end of chapter 3 on is
Paul is building up to what what will be
his his final attempt to reconcile the
the the goodness of the law with the
inability of the law to to affect a
relationship with God that's his
position on the matter and he'll do that
in Chapter 7 so just preparing the way
for this you know and he does so in
verse 20 of chapter 5 but the law came
in with the result that trespass
multiplied but where sin increased grace
abounded all the more so that just as
sin exercise Dominion and death so grace
might also exercise Dominion through
justification leading to eternal life in
Jesus Christ yeah so he's celebrating
the reality at the same time as noting
something about the law the law is not a
way of dealing in his mind with the
reality of sin it just multiplies yeah
don't you I think I won't do the don't
you think I think this is still his
reading of Genesis two and three that
that Adam and Eve's sin is multiplied
because now they do it against the law
they don't just do the wrong thing they
do the wrong thing against my explicit
commandment right don't eat that and
they eat it you'll be alluding to that
and he was so very specifically I think
it's already creeping in yeah look can I
ask you with the toughest question which
we didn't prepare for an answer so I'm
looking forward to your answer on verse
18 therefore just as one man's trespass
led to condemnation for all
so one man's act of righteousness leads
to justification and
if not just for those in Christ but for
all what do you do with that
sneaking universalism mm-hmm in Paul's
claims that you know I think one of the
things that's going on here is an
anticipation of the arguments he's going
to be mounting in chapters 9 through 12
yeah and his ID on't I think we miss
read Paul if we tried to make him into a
19th or 20th century rationalist yeah
who's wrestling with the problem of
singularity versus universality whatever
that's right I think Paul has the sense
that God's will is to bring all of
humankind into relationship with God and
that God has provided a way of doing so
through the the graciousness of his his
gift and through the faithful response
to that gracious gift in Christ yeah and
that that is the one way in which all
can relate to God through accepting
God's gracious gift for you know modern
theologians and and church folk that the
issue is is that one way confined only
to Christ or is it the form with the
relationship that's exactly what yeah
the acceptance of gracious and the
churches and theologians divide ah yeah
but I think Paul's Paul's vision here is
an eschatological veil a vision of hope
a vision of a universal relationship of
all of humankind with God that works on
this fundamental principle yeah God's
gift
our faithful reason oh I agree and I
think the one thing that this rules out
is the kind of Christianity which says
fortunately I'm saved and you're not
that the hope has to be broader than
what happens to you and me it has in
that sense the hope is universal though
the exact shape of that hope I think is
hard to figure right and it's it's
interesting here to note the language
justification and life and indeed Paul
will link justification in life but
there's always judgment involved too
there is and so the language of being
saved although Paul can use that
language sometimes to refer to the side
of the process usually it refers you to
the end of the process yeah all right
we'll look more at that